hola mi nombre es jimena barriga soy
licenciada en administración de empresas
de entretenimiento básicamente mi
trabajo es coordinar eventos contactar a
los artistas checar el audio la
iluminación y que todo fluya bien en los
eventos bueno eso tuviera contado de mi
si un voluntariado no hubiera cambiado
mi vida te voy a contar pero primero
retrocedamos un poco en el tiempo cuando
yo tenía 16 años trabajaba en
campamentos básicamente me pagaban por
divertirme y es que imagínate tres días
en valle de bravo corriendo brincando
jugando en la alberca prendiendo una
fogata y viendo el cielo con más
estrellas que te puedas imaginar como le
podían llamar a eso trabajo pero bueno
no nos salgamos del tema a mí lo que me
gustaba en estar jugando y cantando con
los niños un día cuando estaba en el
campamento una amiga me contó que ella
era voluntaria en club amigos teletón un
programa de inclusión donde jóvenes
voluntarios conviven con niños y niñas
con discapacidad de los centros de
rehabilitación de teletón
ahí ellos juegan conviven hacen amigos y
me dijo que era hacer más o menos lo
mismo que en el campamento yo amaba mi
trabajo y si podía hacer lo mismo que me
gustaba y además ayudar a alguien sonaba
como el mejor clan así que le dije
nunca imaginé que un bar fuera a cambiar
mi vida por completo pasaron los días y
llegó el día de la capacitación recuerdo
que escuché por primera vez las palabras
rehabilitación e inclusión esperanza y
terapia física
terapia física qué es eso o sea cómo
puedo estudiarlo y dedicarme a eso el
resto de mi vida de un segundo a otro
todo lo que tenía en mi vida planeado
cambió y es que estaba cambiando de
organizar grandes eventos por besos en
el cachete embarrados de paleta estaba
cambiando de conocer artistas por
enseñar a caminar y ver que no hay
imposibles y sobre todo de una vida de
fama por una vida mucho más humana
es increíble como lo que comenzó como un
juego de verano se estaba convirtiendo
en un estilo de vida y es que de repente
ya no sólo era voluntario en teletón
también estaba en una casa hogar estaba
haciendo colectas de juguetes de ropa
estaba de misiones o uno de mis
favoritos en el cerro corriendo de un
lado al otro llena de lodo
eso sí cuando eres voluntario te vas a
acostumbrar a que siempre te digan las
mismas cosas
eres un ángel
qué bueno que te gusta ayudar o si no
también te van a decir o sea cómo te
despiertas temprano estas en la nada y
no te pagan estás loca
lo que ellos no saben es que muchas
veces las aventuras que vivimos nos dan
mucho más que un cheque a la quincena de
voy a contar tres cosas que yo aprendí
en el voluntariado número uno
no creas que solamente vas a ir a dar
porque la verdad cuando regresas a casa
regresas con mucho más amor más
enseñanzas y más amigos de los que
esperas número 2 no creas que al ser
voluntario eres un superhéroe pero si
eres una mejor persona y número 3
se te va a volver una adicción y un
estilo de vida que le va a dar un giro
por completo
a lo mejor tú me vas a decir gimen a mí
no me gustan los niños ok
hay voluntariados con adultos
la verdad es que me he ido en la vida es
correr que te parecería correr al lado
de una persona con baja visión o con
ceguera lo mío lo mío son los animales
pues no hay libro a tortugas y si a ti
lo que te gusta es viajar no sé qué
esperas para buscar un voluntariado en
cualquier parte del mundo si lo que te
detiene es tu trabajo pues entonces
combínalo bien dicen por ahí que en 100
años no importar como estamos vestidos
ahorita cuánto dinero tenemos en nuestra
cuenta del banco o qué coche manejamos
pero el mundo si va a ser mucho mejor si
tú fuiste importante en la vida de una
persona
trascender en la vida de una persona
usualmente cuando nos dicen eso siempre
viene nuestra cabeza la palabra niños
porque así con nuestra enseñanza y
ejemplo van a ser mejores personas
conforme pasan los semestres en la
universidad me di cuenta que aquellos
niños con los que a mí me encantaba
trabajar crecen y crecen y crecen hasta
que se vuelven adultas mayores
alguna vez te has puesto a pensar en ser
importante en la vida de un adulto mayor
ok
como ellos ya crecieron y vivieron no
necesitan un granito de nuestra atención
vamos a ver recuerda a tus abuelos
como son
como eran que les gustaba hacer yo tengo
dos versiones
por un lado mi abuela ya ya ella por una
condición de salud estaba sentada frente
a la televisión y así la vimos
deteriorarse
por otro lado mi abuelo anima que hasta
la fecha es una peli no la sube baja que
el café el club de libros las amigas ya
la hace de todo
en méxico actualmente el 10 por ciento
de la población 33 millones de personas
son adultos mayores se espera que en el
año 2030
esta cifra suba al 20% 23 millones de
personas y saben que ellos dependerán de
nosotros y es justo ahí donde comienza
mi idea voy a crear un lugar donde las
personas se vuelvan a sentir ellos un
lugar donde la mirada se centra en la
persona no se enfoque solamente en las
arrugas en las canas o en su lento
caminar porque son personas soy mucho
más allá de su pasado con un presente y
un futuro aún tienen sueños metas y
retos por cumplir
estamos acostumbrados a ver la edad
adulta como la ley de las tres emes
mientras me muero antes de hacer las
personas no dejan de ser responsables de
su propia vida y se vuelven espectadores
de la vida de los demás
a poco ellos siempre están esperando un
día más de vida para ver los logros de
la familia porque no han escuchado que
les dicen
espero llegar al día de tu graduación
me encantaría estar ahí el día de tu
boda apúrate a tener nietos quiero
conocerlos y tenerles una chambita
voy a crear un lugar con grandes salones
con grandes clases
de idioma de pintura
con clases y tardes de juego noches de
dominó
tardes de cartas claramente un área de
terapia física
la idea que vino ya compartirte es
invitarte a cambiar la idea que tienes
hoy de los adultos mayores no son un
álbum de recuerdos ni un cúmulo de
sabiduría son la combinación de su
presente y su futuro
aun con capacidad de crear de descubrir
y de seguir aprendiendo
ven cierra tus ojos acompañan el futuro
vamos a dar una vuelta por los jardines
entremos a la biblioteca y vamos a
llenar este lugar de vida porque vida la
que viene
[Música]